I'm gonna figure out how I can be away
this weekend because a half million
protesters are expected to descend on
Washington to push for more gun control
and school safety hundreds of other
protests are planned around the world on
the same day and we're told that each
March is basically student-led but did
students really organize all of this and
the five weeks since the Florida
shooting let's look into who's really
behind this with Washington free beacon
reporter Steven go Taos ki Steven great
to see you this is just a bunch of kids
having fun and doing what's right in a
time where we need to say enough is
enough
yeah certainly that's the media
narrative on the off this protest right
it's just the kids sort of put this on
all themselves out of the blue they're
just very talented kids yeah
articulate on TV they're on 60 minutes
we might play a sound bite but sure but
the reality is that that's not true
there's a number of groups that are
helping organize this event every town
for gun safety which is Michael
Bloomberg's personally put in how much
money into that group to us
Oh millions in noise he's a
multi-billionaire himself yeah that's
his big issue of gun control absolutely
and so they're involved they even
created a new group called students
demand change so they're students they
had action just like me
so we would we you know and again
because it's a 501 C 4 as you wrote in
your piece limited on what information
we can get but we can bet and this has
come out that this is gonna be a massive
push for voter registration and each of
these sites they're gonna have have a
canvass with voter registration stations
so the goal here is yeah it's it's to
change policy rights change the law take
that power the goal is to take back
power and in the midterms drive that
election narrative going into 2020 and
it's the same kind of folks that are
bought with that were behind the woman's
March correct yes some of them are
absolutely involved in organizing this
and flying for permits for the March as
well and and the group itself that
they've created the c4 that you
mentioned that group is not just
spending the money they've raised on
this particular March they've also said
they're going to spend it going for it
on other lobbying oh very interesting
well we should be all excited because
George Clooney and his wife and his two
children are coming because he'd wrote a
check he just sold that big tequila
company for like me and I think he made
personally 500 million off that not a
bad payday so he wrote a five hundred
thousand dollar check that's chump
change to this group but he's gonna be
there so they're gonna have a celebrity
push much like The Woman's March and
they this is all part of an
organizational effort to drive the
political narrative correct yeah that's
absolutely right I mean it's not just
George Clinton either it's also Oprah
Winfrey donated half a million dollars
so did Steven Spielberg Jeffrey
Katzenberg so there's certainly a lot of
nieces they're all back it's the Clinton
Easter's yeah well so the still have
time to play it but the students went on
60 minutes they're getting the full
media push and it is it is it is gonna
be blanketing the country well we see
the graphic do we have the graphic that
we can put up from the from the March
where the actual yeah it means look at
that you can't even put the red flags
alright I mean you got to hand it to
them they got the money behind them and
they got the organization will this have
big impact do you think in November is
this an issue that drives the electorate
you know it hasn't been in the past
right well in in a probably the opposite
direction of what the organizers want I
mean in the past guns have been an issue
that Republicans have dominated that
people that voters have gone to
Republicans for because they prefer
their policies yeah so the Second
Amendment types like whoa this there
there this is unfair they're coming
after our guns law-abiding people's guns
we got to get out there and vote so it
could have a boomerang effect but
they're gonna register a lot of people
to vote Stephen great work on the peace